[Musique]
le 19 juin dernier a eu lieu au golf des
yvelines le 4e open tv 78 retour sur cet
événement avec le président de tv 78
laurent basauri la directrice du golf
des yvelines catherine espinasse et
quelques-uns des nombreux sponsors de la
compétition
[Musique]
et bien aujourd'hui donc se tenait au
château de la couarde dans les yvelines
au golf des yvelines le 4e open et oui
déjà le 4e open tv 78 50 ans devine
département des yvelines de golf 4e open
comme son nom l'indiqué est ouvert à
tous les compétiteurs aussi bien les
plus aguerris que même des compétiteurs
débutants c'est l'intérêt de cette
compétition cette compétition pour sa
quatrième année a donc choisi le goal
des yvelines sa particularité c'est que
chaque année elle tourne elle change de
golf elle a lieu dans un groupe
différent
toujours dans le département des
yvelines nous étions l'année dernière à
50 ans ni viennent et nous sommes cette
année à la queue-lez-yvelines dans ce
merveilleux golf du château de la
couarde donc à la fois une compétition
sportive de haut niveau de grand intérêt
mais également un lieu magique et
magnifique des yvelines qui met en
osmose à la fois l'aspect sportif mais
également l'aspect touristique qui est
important pour nous dans les yvelines de
faire valoir ce territoire qui est à la
fois une terre de sport mais également
un lieu touristique très fréquentée nous
l'espérons par beaucoup d'étrangers qui
viennent pratiquer ce beau sport mais
également des rites ou découvert notre
territoire
[Musique]
cette compétition a une particularité
c'est qu'elle sait maintenant bien
installé dans le paysage golfique
franciliens et j'irai même dans le
paysage golfique des télévisions locales
puisque c'est le seul open organisé par
une télévision locale dans l'ensemble de
la france dont c'est la quatrième
édition est donc vous le voyez cet open
s'inscrivant dans la durée
d'abord parce que il reste dans ce
périmètre des yvelines ensuite parce que
c'est la quatrième année et puis il est
annonciateur d'un grand événement les
trois premières éditions annoncé la
ryder cup qui a eu lieu dans les
yvelines et partir mans à saint quentin
en yvelines et cette quatrième édition
annoncent les jeux olympiques on lui en
2024 à nouveau au golf national
donc je pense qu'à minima la durée ira
au moins jusqu'en 2024
et je suppose que nous continuerons bien
au delà en témoigne le nombre des
participants aujourd'hui nous sommes aux
alentours de 80 participants donc j'en
profite pour ceux qui nous regardent
n'hésitez pas à vous inscrire l'année
prochaine donc oui il s'est inscrit dans
le paysage je pense qu'un grand moment
récurrent à la fois qui allie beaucoup
de sponsors
on aura certainement l'occasion d'en
parler pendant cette émission mais
également beaucoup de particuliers qui
viennent et bien se confronter
confronter leurs talents et puis
découvrir encore une fois ce territoire
mais également découvrir tous nos
partenaires qui sont tous des
partenaires très agissant dans le monde
du golf
et tout naturellement sur les yvelines
et saint quentin en yvelines
[Musique]
alors à titre personnel avec mon
coéquipier ah oui parce que c'est une
compétition sous formule qu'on appelle
le scramble donc c'est passionnant
rigole parce qu'on décrit très souvent
ce sport comme un sport individuel mais
là nous sommes en compétition par
équipes ce qui rajoute évidemment
quelque chose d'intéressant on choisit
la meilleure balle pour pouvoir jouer
donc ça donne évidemment un peu de
stratégie au jeu et puis un peu plus
d'humanisme probablement qu'un jeu
individuel donc pour moi écouter ça
s'est plutôt bien passé avec mon
partenaire on était très content mais
quand on a confronté nos scores en
rentrant s'est rendu compte que on est
certainement pas les gagnants des
conditions parce qu'ils avaient quand
même du très bon niveau et le bateau est
quand même très relevé pour des amateurs
donc
nous sommes contents de jouer avec nous
avons passé mais nous ne gagnons très
certainement pas cette compétition
[Musique]
alors j'ai toujours heureux et flatté
d'être avec karine et speed à ce qui
était une grande championne de golf qui
est aujourd'hui la directrice des lieux
des yvelines et vous avez accueilli la
compétition tv 78 c'est important pour
un point club de d'accueillir comme ça
des compétitions oui c'est important
puisque l'image de notre golf forcément
est véhiculée par ce genre d'événement
cette compétition qui était très
intéressant puisqu'on avait des gens de
chez nous des membres et pour les gens
de l'extérieur donc toujours intéressant
de faire découvrir notre parcours à ceux
et celles qui ne le connaissent pas et
puis nos membres sont contents de
pouvoir jouer d'autres d'autres
personnes s'étaient très bien doté une
très belle remise des prix était très
jolie sponsors donc effectivement un
événement en plus en semaine
oui en semaine c'est le mardi ou jeudi
mercredi c'est très bien
c'était très bien oui et alors les eaux
qui participent à cette compétition de
découvrir pour certains les autres y
sont membres dont ils le connaissent ce
parcours de d2 de la queue-lez-yvelines
des yvelines parcours magnifique alors
avec entretenu formidablement ça c'est
beaucoup de boulot quand même c'est
beaucoup de boulot c'est une équipe qui
est très très performante parce que
finalement ils sont sous effectifs et
sont que 8 pour gérer et 27 trous on a
reçu la semaine dernière donc le
championnat de france dames la coupe
gaveau que tu n'est prêt fédéral et d'où
la raison du dirait d'un parcours
préparé championnat comme vous l'avez pu
le constater son parcours vraiment
exceptionnel mais effectivement c'est un
travail constant toute l'année depuis
maintenant des années a beaucoup
d'améliorations beaucoup d'innovations
beaucoup de travaux qui sont faits
régulièrement
donc effectivement je suis très très
fier de mon micro climat parce que on
annonce des pluies des choses comme ça
et puis on des gens vient ici bas est
passé que ceux connus
quels sont les laits alors vos ambitions
de directrice du club pour l'année qui
vient ou les années qui viennent à
plusieurs patricio n'a d'abord sur la
partie sportive très dur parce que moi
en tant que forcément on accueille
maintenant des épreuves fédérales de
haut niveau donc tous les ans on reçoit
une épreuve fédérale importante pour que
d'ici peut-être deux trois ans on puisse
être amenés à recevoir une épreuve
professionnelle c'est vraiment mon
attention la grande envie le parcours
maintenant est prêt pour recevoir les
tâches championnat alors une épreuve
comme une épreuve femme peu importe
c'est pas très grave mais en tout cas
l'idée tout ce que nous faisons plus des
années vont dans les licences leur sens
là et ça serait bien oui et le guen
grande épreuve
je suis très sensible à cela et je sais
que le parti et puis et puis ça fait
beaucoup quand même pour la renommée de
redorer l'image associée à un parcours
un endroit à l'épreuve
c'est toujours intéressant on part de sa
non et que l'encours des viandes à
bamako qu'il connaît pas lancôme qui ne
connaît pas c'est donc toutes ces
actions que nous menons avec nicolas
isnard et propriétaire du golf
et puis toutes mes équipes c'est
effectivement bien évidemment contenter
nos membres contenter nos régions au
jour le jour ça c'est évident mais
derrière tout cela est une ambition
on l'annonçait sans problème d'ici deux
trois ans accueillir une belle épreuve
aura je vous cache pas qu'une épreuve
femme ferait encore plus plaisir
le circuit européen est vraiment en
difficulté dont son terme d'une épreuve
en france pour lutter pour que les
jouets se fédérant tâche serait bien ce
serait bien vous parlez de nicolas buzz
moi cela il faut rappeler que le golfe d
hiddink fait partie appartient à l'as
eupen golf club qui est une société
voilà qui regroupe un certain nombre de
golf et docks les les membres d'ici sont
aussi des membres des autres golfs
sociale ce n'est pas comme d'autres
données des réseaux ou vous pouvez être
à beaune abonnés ou un membre dans un
golf et pouvoir jouer autant vous voulez
sur les autres on aimante dans un golf
quel qu'il soit dans la chaîne et
ensuite vous avez des réductions oui
dans les eaux sur les eaux du fleuve de
la chaîne novotel
mais par contre vous êtes vous pouvez
être moindre que dans un golf être
affectés à 5,9
après des interactions commerciales bien
évidemment pour nos membres
avec des avantages sur pas mal de
produits unique nation alors ben voilà
on va espérer qu'il y ait une grande
grande épreuve qui se déroule si ce golf
le mérite et c'est beaucoup grâce à vous
merci passé j'avais dit espinasse et
patrice merci merci au revoir
[Musique]
alors je suis avec bernard de banque et
vice président de l'agglomération de
saint quentin en yvelines chargée des
sports fait d'abord saint-quentin
d'agglomération soutient cet open tv de
1,18
alors on est effectivement très très
heureux de soutenir cet open donc de tv
78 saint quentin en yvelines bien sûr
territoire de golf avec le golf national
après donc la ryder cup nous allons
accueillir au mois d'octobre
du 17 au 20 octobre l'open de france et
on va monter en puissance sur l'ensemble
du territoire de saint quentin sur les
trois golfs puisqu'on a un golf sur
l'île de loisirs le golf aussi donc sur
plaisir sur lequel on accueillera un
certain nombre de manifestations il a
levé la sur lequel on accueillera des
manifestations en vue de monter en
puissance d'ici 2024 pour les jeux
olympiques où on accueillera les
épreuves donc des jo sur le gall finale
du saut nationale donc encore un brave à
un grand bravo pour cette initiative ça
fait découvrir les différents golfe qui
assurent le territoire des yvelines les
yvelines sont riches en matière
d'équipement golfique je possède un
département qui a le plus de gains mais
voilà attendait plus des deux plus deux
côtés et il faudrait les faire connaître
d'ailleurs parce que je pense qu'on
pourrait accueillir bon nombre de
personnes au niveau touristique pour
faire découvrir à nos golf et j'espère
que ces manifestations donneront envie à
des gens qui n'ont pas encore pratiquer
le golf d'aller sur les créneaux
merci infiniment werner le monde
[Musique]
à
c'est les batailles bonjour vous êtes un
des sponsors de la compétition de tv 78
parce que vous êtes de le pdg le
fondateur de troubles m
qui est la première entreprise de
fabrication de chariots de golf 1 c'est
ça oui on s'est toujours un plaisir pour
nous de le partager
d'abord ces compétitions de golf qui
sont toujours très convivial et c'est un
plaisir pour moi de pouvoir faire une
petite dotation et il faut bien qu'on
fasse plaisir aux gens qui nous font
vivre toute l'année donc
voilà pour moi c'est un véritable
plaisir alors parlons un peu de 3m qui a
fêté il ya trois ans et 40 ans qui à 43
ans donc les armes en trois ans quarante
trois ans vous êtes le leader sur le
marché de du chariot de golf tout à fait
alors on est leader incontesté du
chariot électrique et avec une part de
marché qui avoisine les 60 % aujourd'hui
donc c'est quand même très très
important le sérieux lectrique ça se
développe de plus en plus c'est un
investissement sais pas c'est pas 2 mais
s'est produite il devient indispensable
pour une certaine catégorie de personnes
est un peu les gens un peu parce qu'en
fait il ya pas que des gens en bonne
santé mais malheureusement qui jouit des
gens qui ont les problèmes cardiaques
qui ne peuvent pas faire d'effort vous
et des gens que brême 2-2 genou
d'articulation donc le chariot
électrique est vraiment maintenant
rentré dans les moeurs depuis quelques
années et donc il ya un marché encore
d'équipements et puis un marché de
renouvellement qui est important aussi
club breton aussi qu'est ce qui a changé
depuis que fabriquer des chariots donc
qu'est-ce qui a changé dans le sérieux
et notamment dans les chariots
électriques à batterie d'ailleurs sont
plus en plus légères
il ya environ une dizaine d'années on
est vraiment passés du plomb qui était
extrêmement lourd au lithium
ça a permis à la fois d'avoir des
madriers extrêmement légère mais ça nous
a permis d'alléger aussi les structures
des chariots parce quand on trimballe
une batterie 10 kg le chariot
ne souffre pas de la même manière
qu'avec une batterie d'un kilo donc ça
vit plus longtemps alors c'est pas une
bonne nouvelle pour nous si ses toiles
aux charlots été plus robuste donc il
sera à peu près la même durée de vie
mais il faut savoir que nos modèles et
nos structures évoluent on va toujours
vers des chariots plus petit plus
faciles à manipuler plus facile à ranger
tout à plat et elle crée quand même en
moyenne deux chariots électriques ses
parents différence c'est ça qui est
formidable c'est trop lent pendant votre
dans votre entreprise c'est la
créativité c'est la remise en cause à
chaque fois et il a essayé d'apporter un
nouveau produit qui vous tout à fait mon
cher même si on écoute les clients
et si on fonctionne aussi bien c'est que
les clients
[Musique]
savent qu'on résout leurs problèmes et
qu'on leur propose des produits adaptés
à leurs besoins
donc on fait pas nos produits en fait ce
sont les clients qui essaient eux qui
nous donne les informations pour avoir
le chariot idéal et alors c'est par un
scoop mais je pense que en deux fins de
fin de cette année et début 2000 20 on
va développer un modèle exceptionnel qui
se rendent complètement à plat alors on
avec une autonomie incroyable et les
batteries encore beaucoup plus petit
puisqu'on va développer une technologie
24 volts avec des moteurs plus léger et
un système de fonctionnement vraiment
incroyable on ira le voir dès qui sera
dès qu'ils ont des casiers bataille on
va continuer dans l'électrique on va on
va sortir un tout petit peu du golfe
pour parler de votre fils qui a monté
une société de quoi il s'agit de vélo
donc ils sont arrivés au bon moment avec
le bon concept les ils sont arrivés à un
moment où c'était la fin des batteries
plomb ils sont avec un nouveau concept
avec des batteries lithium et ce qui
leur a permis de se développer très
rapidement et de s'implanter avec une
croissance
exponentielle et aujourd'hui c'est bien
les conti de lui didier voilà et ça
s'appelle pour aux deux fils
c'est bien qu'ils continuent olivier
provost merci beaucoup merci à vous
[Musique]
alors je suis avec arnaud rock vous êtes
un des sponsors de la composition de tv
78 l'ambassadeur d'essence et vous êtes
installé depuis peu à
montigny-le-bretonneux
c'était ça a été un choix de ma part de
venir sur le 78 à saint-quentin
monténégro 2 2 à 1 chez promo paul est
une structure qui est un qui héberge une
centaine de sociétés j'ai installé mais
locaux d'activités pour lesquels enfin
dans lequel je peux à la fois gérer mais
mes activités sur des animations des
nues culinaires et puis aussi pour gérer
en fin d'année les coffrets cadeaux qui
demande une logistique importante et un
peu de surface alors ils vont raconter
ce que ces robots c'est de l'indécence
c'est trois activités
ces trois activités la principale celle
animations dégustations de produits haut
de gamme jeu source le produit depuis
maintenant six ans et pour d'une quote
c'est vraiment des produits l'odyssée
des produits haut de gamme on est sur du
caviar
partout on est sur du spiritueux avec du
whisky du rhum je continue à renouveler
ma gamme perpétuellement est le deuxième
axe c'est le très terne le traiteur donc
c'est de l'animation demandes clients
avec d'une ambiance tapas à la française
toujours du foie gras du caviar de la
truffe des petites girolles il faisait
chaud ce bien qui est qui qui font bien
le qui font bien la dégustation
et puis l'ensemble de ses produits 200
produits 200 produits référencés qui
sont destinés au coffret cadeau cadeaux
d'affaires sur mesure et je couvre le
national et on peut vous trouver ou sur
le site ambassadeur d'essence point
commun est également à
montigny-le-bretonneux chez provost paul
voilà bah voilà tout est dit merci
ambassadeur d'essence et vraiment c'est
des produits vous ne trouverez pas
ailleurs et qui sont extraordinaires je
peux le dire
[Musique]
parmi les sponsors j'accède bon du
magazine farewell j'accepte beau quelle
est la spécificité du magazine farewell
fairway c'est un magazine de golf qui
existe depuis 15 ans qui est dans le
monde du golf le magazine le plus large
on va dire ce qu'on va appeler lifestyle
ou culture golf c'est à dire que nous ne
visons pas le golfeur en tant que
golfeur joueurs mais en fait le golfeur
en tant qu'être humain qui a des
patients qui a des envies qui a de la
consommation aussi et donc en fait on
vient chercher le golfeur un petit peu
partout où il croise des passions c'est
un magazine qui paraît cette fois par an
plus deux magazines exceptionnel grand
format qu'on appelle xxl et un guide
hôtel et golf qui paraît au mois de
décembre tous les ans donc en fait on a
dit publication par an farewell
c'est aussi des compétitions de golf qui
s'appelle les féroé scop qui sont
tournées de douze compétitions plus une
finale liste des rôles au niveau
national mais fairways aussi à des
passions et entre autres l'édition c'est
normal pour un journal et un magazine
et donc nous avons édité il ya deux ans
un jeu un très très beau livre dédié au
golf national réalisé par un très très
grand photographe qui est le plus grand
photographe du golfe
aujourd'hui chères au niveau français
mais peut-être même au niveau mondial je
dirige un magazine mais je suis aussi un
passionné de golf donc bien évidemment
quand ya une belle compétition comme ça
j'en profite pour venir travailler et
venir faire une belle partie de colle
donc aujourd'hui j'ai joué pas très très
bien d'accord mais avec des gens
charmants dans une très bonne ambiance
avec une très belle organisation
une très belle journée et surtout sur un
golf qui est un des golfs parisien qui
mérite d'être vraiment visiter sur
lesquels il faut venir jouer souvent
corps
[Musique]
dans une compétition de golf in et aux
sponsors indispensable et ce sponsor
ségol plus le numéro un de la
distribution du golf en france renault
car il nous en parle
google+ est une enseigne leader sur son
marché qui est l'équipement du matériel
de golf pour les consommateurs golfeur
mais aussi pour les entreprises c'est
une enseigne qui à 37 ans exactement qui
s'est créée à paris dans le xviième par
quelqu'un qui s'appelle patrick schmied
lincent fondateur et l'enseigne s'est
développée depuis 37 ans compte
aujourd'hui 28 points de vente même
bientôt 30
et c'est une enseigne qui est
essentiellement basé en région
parisienne les yvelines compte de très
nombreux golfs
nous avons à proximité à proximité
immédiate de nombreux golfs comme le
golf de bêtement le golf de villennes
sur seine
vous avez également à joyenval saint
germain en laye et j'en passe tellement
il y en a je crois qu'on pourrait dire
que dans un rayon de 14 km en compte 14
golf donc pour l'enseignant gaulle fut
c'était vraiment un point stratégique
qu'il fallait occuper est partenaire de
l'open tv 78 ses supporter une chaîne
locale qui s'intéressent au golf depuis
longtemps mais aussi sept partenaires de
la vie économique golfique locales dont
l'actualité quand même très dense depuis
quelques temps
[Musique]
merci de nous avoir suivi et à très vite
pour reparler de golf sur tv 78
[Musique]